hello hot reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and it's John over here so we've
been asked by many to check out by
mighty raccoon a fantastic Channel
Pennywise it versus the Joker
battle of the clowns this is the matchup
I've been waiting for this is the
matchup we saw the trailer for it and
now it's finally here Pennywise
that's who creates this channel hey good
job answer funny like that that's a
funny name violence blood bad leaders we
can have I can handle that kind of thing
do anything we've put together recently
can't do that
[Music]
leave me alone I'll break your bones
[Music]
guys give me good this is gonna be
really good
[Music]
[Music]
no now I guess I'm not in Arkham Asylum
anymore
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a great voice these people don't
even recognize me
Joker dies
[Music]
greatest feeders
[Music]
this is really starting to piss me off
Quinzel it's afraid of love
why did you wear that stupid outfit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
someone is big trouble
what did you do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who's on the reaping you'll [ __ ] down
here [ __ ] what are you doing
scary-looking Jason Todd the crowbar
[Music]
[Music]
okay cowboy you got what you want do
what you want with me
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
puncher can't trick the Joker
[Music]
[Music]
objective
[Music]
very well done yeah well done you know
it's gonna ask is this all like scratch
animation or some of these like skins
like is that the Joker from the Arkham
Asylum game or something or is it I
think it's just uh well obviously this
most recent one 8-bit misfit I think the
latest Joker's from one of the Arkham
games like yeah the argument spiration
he did what I was hoping he would do
I remember saying we've seen the trailer
I hope that he toys with the psychology
a little bit more oh yeah it had a
really cool build up with that stuff
having it be like he's psychologically
torturing him and figuring out what
would get under the Joker's skin it
would be cool just to watch them fight
but at the same time there's philosophy
behind both characters that would make
that a fascinating yeah yeah and I was
hoping that he would do that really toy
with the Joker's mine he gave us exactly
that yes he Pierce's my Batman Jason
Todd Harley Quinn in there which I
greatly appreciated and it really did
feel like nightmarish and haunting as
we've seen other stuff remember we were
just like oh damn sick cool lighten this
time I was like whoa I'm not even really
responding vocally yeah they keep it
scary weird and twisted I appreciated
that he went out of his way to make it
that way yeah well I wasn't sure what
was gonna go down Alton yeah you know I
didn't know if they were just gonna
fight or if we would get a little bit
more but it was kind of this interesting
comic piece yeah yeah you know I had a
nice idea and a nice build up to cuz it
starts you know taking its time and then
it slowly ramps up energy and by the
time they're like all-out brawling like
it makes sense it's well paced yeah it
doesn't feel like cool violence
surprisingly yeah which I thought it
would be like Oh bunch of cool cool
characters fighting each other acid I
actually feel like this is kind of nasty
well yeah it's it's one of the few like
hypothetical matchup scenarios where I'm
like you know even though Pennywise is
like a it is a supernatural entity that
takes on many forms and depends on you
that's a tall order cuz the Joker
more real-world character but at the
same time you know I feel like the Joker
could figure that fight out yeah he
could and it seemed it seemed like he
did for a second when it was Harley
Quinn I thought we were gonna devote a
lot of time to that yeah oh great yeah
in my head I'm like I'm a little annoyed
is gonna linger and there's suddenly
puts the dynamite in her mouth I'm like
I love that yeah yeah cuz the Joker he's
figured out the game he realizes what's
going on and I thought that was very
clever and well done kind of has that
Freddy vs. Jason ending yeah yeah of
course because about time Joker wins
like there's no way the Joker what a one
just based off that yeah yeah it's the
beginning I hope we get a rematch soon
I'll get a spin-off movie of it but but
just about the Joker's team oh yeah they
should really team up that would be
sweet yeah man the Joker handles the
money side and it handles the terrors I
really respected the hell out of that I
would have appreciate that as being an
actual comic book hey man there are a
lot of great you know comic book matte
mashups and crossovers Pennywise being
the thing right now be kind of cool
rights always a thing you could get that
just transcribe whatever that was a back
story yeah converse is gonna be one big
plagiarism so it's kind of well you know
I mean in a weird way there's there's
elements of that in the biz already
because every comic book movie that
comes out practically it's like we kind
of based on this storyline and then
above this storyline from this comic
book and stuff and then we threw in a
couple of things of our own that are
gonna piss you guys off and I'm just for
the complicated take screenshots yeah of
this video and turn it into a comic book
I'm sure some of these panels have been
all right well mighty raccoon
congratulations there was a lot of
buildup and anticipation for that and I
think you really delivered on that man
that was fantastic job fantastic hey
guys subscribe to the reel rejects
please click that notification bell you
can follow dat John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram I'm on Twitter and
Instagram as well make sure to check out
our patreon become a patron eject today
join us